counting steps on my aura ring what is
that well I got the Fitbit and it counts
my steps oh wait oh there was a ring
that didn't and then it like it buzzes
you and goes like you haven't gotten up
in six hours it reminds me I like my my
phone is like get up yeah my phone will
say or my I'll have a those Garmin
wristwatches and it'll soubise like move
or in the morning it tells you how much
you slept yeah and you it's you know it
has like a little graph right and for me
there's always like a like line where I
was like up for three hours looking at
YouTube videos and then it goes by again
right mine knows when I've had an erotic
fantasy burned out a while ago
do you still have those what erotic
fantasies yeah like they're not what
they used to do when you're you know as
you get as one gets older and and one
approaches a you know mid mid mid to
late middle age one doesn't dream of the
things one dreamt about you know sexy
ladies now I dream about just even
longer sleep like slightly slightly
longer more restful sleep that's all I
dream about yeah I'm in the best shape
of my life you are didn't go with you on
there that's the sign I'm in the best
shape my life and you turned out to them
and there was just a you know I I saw
Jon Lovitz at at this event and he
looked great yeah and I said John you
look so good he's like I'm using ctrl-x
shampoo thing every day you use it it
makes your hair a little darker yeah and
then when you like how it looks just
stop using it so I started using it and
my hair suddenly got crazy dark and I
looked exactly like Paul man o forth I
wasn't sure why I was listening to
fashion advice he's one of the strangest
I love John Lovett and I work with him
on starting out live 150 years ago back
when it was in black and white and he's
such so he's such a lovely guy but man
he is such a character all the time
whenever I saw him doing anything like
he's with an attractive woman I'd say
hey John oh and you know and he'd
introduced me to his date and then he'd
be like in front of her ego in jealous
[Laughter]
and you do that about everything he'd
have a cookie and be like now that looks
like a dick jealous no there's more of
them right there I think you have way to
move through life don't you think that's
energy all that energy all the time